- Please, please.
(audience cheering)
Please, please.
Don't stop. Please.
(audience cheering)
No and don't adjust your sets.
Kelly did not decide to
part her hair everywhere.
It's me. It's Howie Mandel.
I'm kind of nervous, but
you're in for a real good time
and no, you listen, I love this show.
Even when I'm not here, I never miss it
and I don't want to change a thing.
If it ain't broke, don't fix it.
So this is the part where
Kelly usually sings, right?
So who's ready for some Howie-okie?
(audience cheering)
Hit it.
(upbeat instrumental music)
♪ Here's the thing ♪
♪ We started out friends ♪
♪ It was cool, but it was all pretend ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Since you've been gone ♪
♪ All you ever hear me say is ♪
♪ How I picture me with ♪
♪ That's all you'd ever hear me say ♪
♪ But since you been gone ♪
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm sorry.
No, no, no.
You guys were not on, anyway.
No, it's not their fault.
You are an amazing band.
I always listen to you.
You are amazing.
You just didn't have enough
time to get into my key.
- [Speaker] Yeah.